>> Sean: WHAT AN INTRODUCTION.
THANKS, TUCKER.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
IT'S HAVE A SPECIAL MESSAGE.
YOU DON'T WANT TO MISS IT.
FORMER PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA.
THAT'S STRAIGHT AHEAD.
AFTER MORE THAN 100 DAYS IN
OFFICE, ONE OVERREACHING THEME
IS DOMINATING NOW SIPPY CUP
JOE'S ADMINISTRATION.
THAT THEME IS COMPLETE WEAKNESS.
WEAKNESS ABROAD, WEAKNESS AT
HOME.
A WEAK COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF THAT
BELIEVES THAT FULL SCALE
APPEASEMENT OF OUR ENEMIES WILL
BRING PEACE IN OUR TIME.
JOE'S COWARDLY RESPONSE TO THE
RUSSIAN HACK IS EMBARRASSING AND
SELF-DISRUPTIVE.
NOW ONLY DID HE GIVE THEM A FREE
PASS ON THE RUSSIANS HACKING THE
PIPELINE, FIVE DAYS LATER, GET
THIS, JOE REWARDED HIS PAL,
PUTIN, BY REMOVING TRUMP ERA
SANCTIONS ON A KEY RUSSIAN
PIPELINE THAT HOPES OUR ALLIES
IN GERMANY AND ELSEWHERE IN
EUROPE.
NOT ONLY IS AMERICA FIRST'S
STRATEGY GONE, DEAD, ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE IS NOW GONE.
THAT IS DEAD.
NOW JOE IS LITERALLY ADOPTED
VLADIMIR PUTIN AND RUSSIA FIRST
STRATEGIES AND GIVING A WAIVER
TO VLADIMIR PUTIN TO BUILD HIS
PIPELINE AND TURNING DOWN OURS.
FINDS OUT THE REAL RUSSIAN
COLLUSION, YEAH, THAT WOULD BE
LEADING DEMOCRATS.
REMEMBER OBAMA, TELL PUTIN I'LL
HAVE MORE FLEXIBILITY AFTER THE
ELECTION.
HILLARY CLINTON PAYING FOR THE
DIRTY RUSSIAN DOSSIER AND USED
AS THE BASIS TO SPY ON A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE AND A
PRESIDENT WITH PREMEDITATED
FRAUD ON A FISA COURT.
DON'T FORGET HUNTER BIDEN'S 3.5
MILLION HE GOT FROM A RUSSIAN
OLIGARCH, THE FIRST LADY OF
MOSCOW.
NOW JOE DESTROYS IN AMERICA
HIGH-PAYING CAREER JOBS IN THE
ENERGY SECTOR BY SHUTTING DOWN
OUR PIPELINE WITH THE STROKE OF
A PEN, ENDING OUR ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE, ALLOWING A WAIVER
SO PUTIN CAN BUILD A PIPELINE TO
SUPPLY TO OUR ALLIES.
JOE GAVE THE GREEN LIGHT, TWO
THUMBS UP.
ONE OF OUR BIGGEST GEO POLITICAL
FOES THAT RELIES ON OIL AND GAS
IN RUSSIA TO FUND THEIR PROXY
WARS, ALL THE NEFARIOUS
ACTIVITIES THEY'VE BEEN INVOLVED
IN INCLUDING SABOTAGING AMERICA
AT EVERY CHANCE AND IT'S EVEN
WORSE THAN THAT.
NOW THE SAME CAN ALSO BE SAID
ABOUT SIPPY CUP JOE AND IRAN.
JOE IS WORKING HARD AGAIN TO
LIFT SANCTIONS AGAINST THE
MULLAHS IN IRAN.
SO WHY WOULD WARM MILKY BEDTIME
STORY JOE BE SO EAGER TO LIFT
THE SANCTIONS ON RUSSIAN OIL AND
IRANIAN OIL AND DESTROYING
AMERICAN ENERGY INDEPENDENCE AT
HOME?
ONE WORD.
JOE APPEASEMENT.
APPEASEMENT FOR ENEMIES A BROAD
AND HIS RADICAL BASE HERE AT
HOME.
WE'RE WATCHING THIS PLAY OUT IN
ISRAEL.
FIRST BIDEN REINSTATED AMERICAN
FUNDING TO THE PALESTINIANS.
DONALD TRUMP HAD CUT IT OFF.
SOON AFTER, HAMAS BEGAN
LAUNCHING THOUSANDS OF IRANIAN
SUPPLIED ROCKETS RIGHT INTO
ISRAELI CITIES.
NOW JOE APPARENTLY WANTS ISRAEL
TO STOP DEFENDING ITSELF WITH A
UNILATERAL CEASE FIRE.
WHAT WOULD HE DO IF THOSE
ROCKETS WERE BEING FIRED INTO
AMERICAN CITIES?
IN OTHER WORDS, THAT WORD, ONE
WORD, APPEASEMENT.
BACK HERE AT HOME, JOE IS ALSO
APPEASING HIS RADICAL
ANTI-SEMITIC BASE.
RASHEEDA TALIB HITTING ISRAEL
AND THE JEWISH PEOPLE THAT LIVE
THERE.
SHE RETWEETED A STATEMENT
CALLING FOR ISRAEL'S
ELIMINATION.
EARLIER THIS YEAR, SHE HELD A
FUND RAISER WITH A NOTORIOUS
ANTI-SEMITE THAT REFERRED TO
JEWS AS SATANIC.
SHE ALSO OPENLY COMPLAINED ABOUT
THE BIDEN'S ADMINISTRATION TO
APPOINT A JEWISH SECRETARY OF
STATE.
TALIB WORRIED THAT BLINKEN, THE
SECRETARY OF STATE WOULD BE TOO
PRO ISRAEL BECAUSE HE'S JEWISH.
WORST OF ALL, TALIB ONCE TALKED
ABOUT I DON'T KNOW HOW THIS
HAPPENED, HER CALMING FEELING
SHE GETS WHEN SHE THINKS ABOUT
THE HOLOCAUST.
THE STATEMENT EXPLAINS IT IN
CONTEXT.
NEVER ONCE DID SHE MENTION THE
MILLIONS OF JEWISH PEOPLE
SLAUGHTERED IN THE HOLOCAUST.
>> I THINK OF THE HOLOCAUST AND
IT'S A CALMING FEELING.
THE FACT THAT IT WAS MY
ANCESTORS, PALESTINIANS THAT
LOST THEIR LAND AND SOME LOST
THEIR LIVES.
LIVELIHOOD, HUMAN DIGNITY, THEIR
EXISTENCE IN MANY WAYS HAVE BEEN
WIPED OUT.
ALL OF IT.
IT WAS IN THE NAME OF TRYING TO
CREATE A SAFE HAVEN FOR JEWS
POST THE HOLOCAUST.
I LOVE THE FACT IT WAS MY
ANCESTORS THAT PROVIDED THAT IN
MANY WAYS.
BUT THEY DID IT IN A WAY THAT
TOOK THEIR HUMAN DIGNITY AWAY,
RIGHT?
IT WAS FORCED ON THEM.
>> Sean: CLEARLY SHE'S A MANIAC,
AN ANTI SEMITE, SPENDS HER TIME
OBSESSING OVER THE STATE OF
ISRAEL.
SHE SHOULD NOT BE IN ANY ELECTED
OFFICE FRANKLY EVER.
YESTERDAY SHE MEETS BIDEN ON THE
TARMAC IN MICHIGAN ACCORDING TO
NUMEROUS REPORT CHEWING HIM OUT
FOR HIM SUPPORTING OUR CLOSEST
ALLY, ONLY DEMOCRACY IN THE
REGION IN THE MIDDLE EAST AND
THEIR RIGHT TO DEFEND ITSELF THE
WAY WE WOULD DEFEND OURSELVES.
REMEMBER, THE SAME WOMAN THAT
HAD TO BE FORCIBLY REMOVED FROM
A TRUMP RALLY IN 2015.
THIS IS NOT A RATIONALE
PEACE-LOVING INDIVIDUAL.
BIDEN?
GIVES HER TEN MINUTES ON THE
TARMAC, REFUSES TO CONDEMN THE
ANTI-SEMITES IN HIS PARTY.
SAME GOES FOR PELOSI, SAME GOES
FOR SCHUMER.
IT'S CLEAR NOW MORE THAN EVER,
THE RADICAL GREEN NEW DEAL,
SOCIALIST SQUAD, THEY NOW RULE
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY ALONG WITH
BERNIE WHO HONEYMOONED IN THE
FORMER SOVIET UNION, PRAISED
CASTRO AND DANIELLE ORTEGA AND
CHAVEZ.
THE LOADERS COWER BEFORE THE
RADICAL SQUAD.
THE PRESIDENT PRAISED ON TALIB
HOURS AFTER THAT ENCOUNTER ON
THE TARMAC.
PERHAPS HE WAS INTIMIDATED.
JOE BIDEN IS BEYOND ANYTHING
ELSE WEAK AND HE'S SPINELESS,
CLEARLY AFRAID OF THE RADICAL
SQUADS.
PRETTY MUCH DOES EVERYTHING THAT
THEY SAY.
WHAT ELSE DID YOU EXPECT FROM A
GUY THAT CAN BE BLOWN OVER THREE
TIMES SO THEY TELL US FROM A
GUST OF WIND.
TODAY DURING A RARE APPEARANCE
OUTSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE, BIDEN
EMBARRASSED HIMSELF AGAIN IN A
SPEECH THAT WAS FRANKLY, YEAH,
PAINFUL TO WATCH.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I BROUGHT WITH ME A FORMER
ACADEMY GRAD WHO NOW SERVES AS
MY COAST GUARD MILAB.
LIEUTENANT COMMANDER -- I'M
GOING TO EMBARRASS HERE.
JANET MACRONE OF THE CLASS OF
2007.
>> WE'RE ENDOWED BY THE -- THE
THING.
YOU KNOW, THE THING.
ENDOWED BY OUR CREATOR.
GOD.
THE CREATOR OF EVERYTHING, JOE.
UNFORTUNATELY IT GOT WORSE.
1 POINT HE ATTEMPTED TO DELIVER
A JOKE.
GOT HIS WORDS MIXED UP.
AFTER NOBODY LAUGHED, JOEY CAME
VERY ANGRY.
HE WANTED A SIPPY CUP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I CAN ONLY ASSUME THAT YOU
WILL ENJOY EDUCATING YOUR FAMILY
ABOUT HOW THE COAST GUARD IS
"THE HARD NUCLEUS AROUND THE
NAVY FORMS IN TIMES OF WAR."
YOU ARE -- YOU'RE A REALLY DULL
CLASS.
COME ON, MAN.
IS THE SUN GETTING TO YOU?
I WOULD THINK YOU'D HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY WHEN I SAY THAT
ABOUT THE NAVY TO CLAP.
BUT BEING HERE TOGETHER --
[APPLAUSE]
BEING HERE TOGETHER IS A VICTORY
IN ITSELF.
>> Sean: WE DID GET THE
SIGNATURE "COME ON, MAN."
NOW WE KNOW WHY HIS TEAM ORDERS
HIM NOT TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
TRUE TO FORM, HIS ATTEMPT AT A
JOKE WAS NOT AN ORIGINAL.
UNLIKE JOE, PRESIDENT RONALD
REAGAN, ABOUT THE SAME AGE AS
JOE AT THAT TIME IN HIS
PRESIDENCY, HE COULD ACTUALLY
DELIVER A PUNCH LINE FOR
COMPARISON.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT PRESIDENT
REAGAN AND BIDEN BACK-TO-BACK.
WE'LL LET YOU DECIDE IF YOU SEE
A DIFFERENCE.
>> MY CLOSE GUARD AIDES HAVE
BEEN EXCELLENT.
ONE OF THEM TAUGHT ME THAT --
AND I QUOTE -- THE COAST GUARD
IS THAT HARD NUCLEUS ABOUT WHICH
THE NAVY FORMS IN TIMES OF WAR.
[CHEERS & APPLAUSE]
>> I CAN ONLY ASSUME THAT YOU
WILL ENJOY EDUCATING YOUR FAMILY
ABOUT HOW THE COAST GUARD IS
"THE HARD NUCLEUS AROUND THE
NAVY FORMS IN TIMES OF WAR."
YOU ARE A REALLY DULL CLASS.
COME ON, MAN.
>> Sean: COME ON, MAN.
YOU'RE A DULL PRESIDENT THAT CAN
BARELY STRING A FEW SENTENCES
TOGETHER.
PIECE OF ADVICE, JOEY, STOP
INSULTING OUR SOLDIERS WHEN THEY
DON'T LAUGH AT YOUR TERRIBLE
JOKES.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER THIS.
>> AND I WANT YOU TO KNOW NOT
WITHSTANDING WHO YOU MAY HEAR
ABOUT ME, I HAVE INCREDIBLY GOOD
JUDGMENT.
ONE, I MARRIED JILL.
TWO, I APPOINTED JOHNSON TO THE
ACADEMY.
I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THANK YOU ALL.
>> Sean: THAT GUY LOOKS BETTER
THAN THAT GUY TODAY.
ANYWAY, I HAVE ANOTHER PIECE OF
ADVICE, JOEY, STEP TELLING
JOKES.
YOU'RE NOT FUNNY AND NEVER WILL
BE AND AS BAD AS MOST OF THE
LAME LATE NIGHT SHOWS ON
TELEVISION NOW.
YOU ALSO MIGHT WANT TO INVEST IN
GOLF LESSONS IF YOU'RE GOING TO
PLAY.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN THERE.
WATCH THAT.
BIDEN STRUGGLES ON THE GOLF
COURSE.
IN THAT CASE, THE BALL WENT
BACKWARDS.
I DON'T HAVE TIME TO PLAY A LOT
OF GOLF.
I PLAYED A FEW ROUNDS IN MY DAY.
I NEVER HIT IT BACKWARDS.
HIT IT OUT OR TO THE LEFT.
JOE IS REPORTEDLY HAVING TROUBLE
WITH VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA
HARRIS, A NEW BOOK IS OUT
CLAIMING THAT DOCTOR -- THE
FIRST LADY, JILL BIDEN SAID THAT
HARRIS CAN GO [BLEEP] HERSELF
WHEN HARRIS CALLED OUT BIDEN'S
HISTORY OF RACISM IN THE FIRST
DEMOCRATIC DEBATE.
SHE WENT SILENT AFTER THAT.
DON'T WORRY.
WE'LL CARRY THE TORCH AND REMIND
PEOPLE FOR YOU, KAMALA.
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS, SHE'S
GETTING CRITICIZED FOR HIDING
HER TREMENDOUS WEALTH BEHIND A
FAMILY TRUST.
THIS ARTICLE ON FOXNEWS.COM, THE
TRUST ASSETS ARE NOT REPORTABLE
EFFECTIVELY OBSCURING SOME OF
THE VICE PRESIDENT'S HOLDING
FROM PUBLIC VIEW.
THIS VIOLATES THE HOLLOW ETHICS
THAT THEY MADE.
REMEMBER, RULES DON'T PLY TO
DEMOCRATS.
ONLY REPUBLICANS.
THEY'RE THE ONLY ONES LUCKY
ENOUGH TO GET 28 GUYS IN
TACTICAL GUNS, PREDAWN RAIDS,
FROGMEN THE BACK YARDS.
CNN CAMERAS THERE TO CAPTURE THE
EVENT.
ONLY THEY GET IN TROUBLE FOR
PROCESS CRIMES LIKE LYING TO
CONGRESS.
DEMOCRATS ARE OCTOBER SAYSED
WITH INSTITUTIONAL RACISM.
LORI LIGHTFOOT -- I CALL HER
LIGHTWEIGHT.
46 PEOPLE SHOT THIS PAST WEEKEND
IN CHICAGO.
BY THE WAY, QUICK EXAM, QUIZ.
DO YOU KNOW THE NAMES OF ANY OF
THEM?
ANYWAY, SHE NOW INSTITUTED A
POLICY BANNING WHITE PEOPLE.
THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED TO INTERVIEW
HER.
ONLY PEOPLE OF COLOR.
THE MAYOR'S OFFICE WILL NOW ONLY
GRAND ONE-ON-ONE INTERVIEWS WITH
BLACK OR BROWN REPORTERS BECAUSE
LIGHTFOOT BELIEVES THERE'S TOO
MANY WHITE PEOPLE WORKING FOR
THE CITY'S NEWS OUTLETS.
NOT ONLY IS THIS OFFICIAL
POLICY, OBVIOUSLY RACIST, BUT
THE MAJOR WOULDN'T BE THE
MAYOR'S TIME BE BETTER SERVED
LOOKING FOR WAYS TO STOP THE
SHOOTSES EVERY WEEKEND IN HER
CITY?
AGAIN, NEARLY 50 PEOPLE THIS
WEEKEND SHOT.
LIGHTFOOT IS MORE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE AMOUNT O